اعتقد ان الاتحاد الاوروبي نجح في تحقيق
بعض الاهداف فهو استطاع ان يصنع من
الاتحاد الاوروبي وحيده من اكبر
الاقتصادات في العالم الاتحاد الاوروبي
نجح حتى الاشهر الاخيره في ان يجعل من
اوروبا وحتى سلام في وقت كانت القاره
مقسمه بالحروب طوال الاف الاعوام اعتقد ان
الاتحاد نجاح في تسهيل علاقات التبادل بين
دول الاوروبيه عندما تكون في برلين او
مدريد في روما او بروكسيل تستخدم العمله
ذاتها وهذا يشكل تقدما كبيرا وطلاب
يتابعون جزءا من دراستهم في بلد اخر ولكن
الطريقه لا تزال طويله وانا عملت مع جاك
شيراك في مجال الدفاع الاوروبي ولا اتحدث
عن الجيش الاوروبي هذا امر مختلف اعتقد ان
جيوش ستبقى وطنيه لفتره لا طويله لاننا
عندما نرسل جنود لتنفيذ مهمات في الخارج
مع وجود مخاطر على حياتهم فعلت الدوله
التي ينتمون اليها ان تتخذ بنفسها قرار
ارسالهام اذ لا يمكن اتخاذ القرار من قبل
هيئه اخرى خارجيه اما الدفاع الاوروبي
فهذا ممكن ويجب العمل كثيرا من اجل التوصل
الى نمط حياه مشترك حتى الان الحمايه
الاجتماعيه لا تزال مختلفه في باريس عما
هي عليه وعلى المواطنين الاوروبيين ان
يشعر بانهم ينتمون الى وطن واحد ينبغي
العمل في مجالات مختلفه حتى في المؤسسات
الرسميه ما استطيع قوله ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي حقق نجاحاتنا في بعض المجالات
وهي كانت ضروريه للعالم ويبقى الكثير مما
يجب العمل من اجله علينا ان نستمر في
العمل من اجل تحسين الاداء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي حيث نرى اليوم ان تجمعات المهمه
هي الصين والهند امريكا الجنوبيه وليس فقط
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اي مجموعات
اقليميه ان لم يجد عدد سكانها على ال 500
مليون نسمه من يكون لهذا التجمع اهميه
اقتصاديه وسياسيه اضافه الى ذلك ان
لاوروبا صوتا تحدثنا في بدايه هذا اللقاء
عن الاستقطاب الثنائي والتعارض بين
الولايات المتحده والصين حاليا الخطر يكمن
في ان تنضم باقي دول العالم الى هذا القطب
او ذلك وقتها ستحدث مواجهه انا اجد انه
على الاتحاد الاوروبي دورا يقوم بها على
غرار ما قام به شارل ديغول في خمسينيات
القرن الفائت عندما قال ليس هذا هو الحل
الحل يكمن في ايجاد طريق ثلاث
الاتحاد الاوروبي اي يجمع كل تلك البلدان
التي لا تريد المواجهه تلك البلدان التي
لا تقف مع الولايات المتحده في صوره كامله
ولا مع الصين في صوره كامله انما لديهم
كلمتهم ووجودهم ومصالحهم الخاصه التي
يدافعون عنها لهذه الاسباب انا اؤمن
بالاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن لا يزال امامنا
الكثير لنقوم به